floods they are clearly catastrophic
traumatic events although they have also
been responsible for one of the most
memorable clips in the history of
broadcast news good morning well
obviously we're getting a nice break
from the rain but not the flooding this
is essentially
that's it James Cameron and
Titanic because that is now officially
the greatest boat disaster ever captured
on film it's over now floods were
everywhere this summer think of them as
the des paseo of natural disasters
persistent ubiquitous and absolutely no
fault of the Puerto Rican government and
floods are always threatening 90% of all
natural disasters in the US involve a
flood which is I assume the reason that
FEMA's website once referred to flooding
as America's number one natural hazard
exclamation mark which is a pretty weird
tone to take were describing something
horrible
it's like saying boils America's number
one staph infection or parks America's
number one place to die unnoticed
and floods are only going to get worse
due to climate change and I know that
there are people who will dispute that
and we just don't have time tonight to
litigate whether extreme weather events
are exacerbated by climate change so for
now let's just say yeah they just
definitely are I mean it is a
complicated issue and we may not have
definitive proof until the late 1980s
but but while floods are often referred
to as natural disasters the truth is the
damage they do is often to some extent
within our control because we have made
certain decisions that put and keep
people and property in the path of
flooding and that is what this story is
about and before we go any further let's
acknowledge that people live near water
for all sorts of reasons for some it's
where their families of limpid
generations or a necessity for the work
that they do or for others it's a luxury
and and living next to the water is
undoubtedly attractive despite the risks
like flooding or stepping on pointy
seashells or mistakenly giving a toasty
toe to a seagull without realizing that
that means that you will now spend the
rest of your life
haunted by a tostito addicted seagull
the point is whatever the reason to live
by the water
learning to offer sake you've got
to be kidding me I don't have any
Tostitos I've been telling you that for
six years look feetoes sorry the point
is the dangers of waterfront living are
real but many people like this man who
lives on the water in Tampa Bay feel the
benefits outweigh the risks mark knows
that life here is tenuous but he doesn't
dwell on it every morning when I walk
out to get the paper I see dolphins
frolicking in the bayou and Roseate
spoonbills walking around the edge of
the Bayou so tends to make you forget
about all those sorts of things sure I
can imagine that seeing a Roseate
Spoonbill would take your mind off
things because you're spending your
whole day trying to figure out how a
flamingo could have gotten it's stupid
bird face stuck into a panini press I'm
just saying even people who like birds
don't like this bird the Audubon Society
an organization whose entire purpose is
to champion birds says they are quote
gorgeous at a distance and bizarre up
close which is like the American Kennel
Club saying we celebrate all dogs and
honor them as man's best friend but the
dandy din Mont has a trash personality
and looks like a Scottie Fox Phil
Spector look if you are literally
overlooking a bar you like that guy you
are probably aware that flooding is a
risk but not every flood prone area is
directly along the coast and sometimes
aggressive development can exacerbate
the risk of flooding even considerably
inland just look at Houston which was
recently rocked by Harvey the metro
areas development has exploded one study
found the Houston area has added 25
percent more pavement over 15 years
replacing soil rich wetlands that could
absorb water with concrete covered
suburbia exactly and that made Harvey's
damage significantly worse concrete
isn't good at absorbing water that is
why people don't dry off at the beach by
rolling around in the parking lot
but but it's not just global warming or
unchecked growth that have put more
people in risky flood prone areas it's
also the fact that it's frequently only
possible for people to take that risk
because they have flood insurance just
look at buying the beach it's a house
hunters type show for people who want to
live near the water and one episode
featured two brothers named Mitch and
Daniel arguing over a particular beach
house which led to this exchange what do
you think about the island house Mitch
well I think there is a lot of good and
a lot of bad on it right awful stepped
into the beach can't be beat we are
really close to the water that's just
another thing that's got me concerned
well that's what insurance is for that's
what insurance is for that may be the
most reckless statement ever said on a
boat and I'm very much including I can
definitely make this shot work let's
beat these goals and Tostitos and don't
have any all I did was say the word get
out of here no touch detox no touch the
dogs but Mitch Lou Tostitos but but
Mitch Mitch isn't wrong that if they
bought that house they could get flood
insurance and surprisingly cheaply and
it's worth taking some time to
understand why that is the case because
unlike other forms of homeowners
insurance flood protection is actually
underwritten by the government through
the NFIP or National Flood Insurance
Program it started nearly 50 years ago
after historic floods wiped out many
people's homes in the 1960s and the
government back then realized that there
was a real problem insurance companies
wouldn't cover floods at an affordable
cost because it was too risky so because
of that the government was spending way
too much on disaster relief so they
stepped in and created the NFIP which
offered significantly discounted
insurance to encourage people to bite
and that sounds great but crucially the
aim at the time was not that people
would be staying in at-risk homes
permanently as the program's current
administrator explains they presumed
that if we told people they were at risk
they would move they presumed that over
the life of the program those discounts
wouldn't need to be continued and they
presumed they would need to be continued
because once people knew they had the
ridge
they would move out that has not proven
true no but of course it hasn't because
that's not how people work we will
gladly accept huge risks to our personal
safety for the sake of a discount so
that was the entire premise behind the
McDonald's dollar menu and that is just
one of the many flaws with how this
well-intentioned program was designed
because everything about it from who
participates to where the money goes to
the incentives it creates needs fixing
and let's start with the fact that
eligibility for the program is
determined through flood plain Maps you
are required to buy flood insurance if
you have a federally backed mortgage and
FEMA's maps show that you live in a
risky area unfortunately the mandate has
been poorly enforced meaning that lots
of people don't buy insurance who should
and the maps themselves can be both
out-of-date and wildly inaccurate in
fact just days before Harvey struck a
study of Houston area flood maps was
published and the results were alarming
over the course of a decade researchers
at Rice University and Texas A&M
Galveston studied one section of
Southeast Harris County they found
FEMA's flood plain Maps missed about 75%
of the damages from the storms
seventy-five percent at that point you
might as well predict floods by having
blindfolded six-year-olds pin little
cardboard puddles onto city maps at
birthday parties but even if all the
maps were perfect there would be another
floor with the NFIP which is how its
administered you see typically the
government doesn't directly insure you
instead
it pays private insurance companies a
fee for every policy they sell but not
just that the federal government is then
responsible for covering any losses
which is a pretty sweet deal for
those companies they take none of the
risk and yet they get all the rewards
but it gets even worse because they also
get paid for each claim they handle and
when frontline crunched some of the
numbers and presented them to inform
ahead of the program they found
something shocking
there was one number that really jumped
out with all the claims in the wake of
Sandy the profits were more than four
hundred million dollars because they're
handling a lot of claims that year and
they get they get make a lot of money
when they hand with
when a big storm hits then they make
more money yeah at the very time you
need them to make less money if anything
because because of the burden is gonna
be borne by the taxpayers they make it
killing that's true for insurance
companies the bigger the disaster the
more they stand to profit and that is a
business model not usually seen outside
of Nicolas Cage's career and while the
insurance industry may dispute exactly
how much profit they make the fact
remains that the government and the
taxpayer are definitely the ones eating
the losses which is one of the reasons
why even before these latest hurricanes
the program was twenty five billion
dollars in debt and there are not enough
Roseate spoonbills in the world to take
your mind off that and just to be clear
there are exactly enough Roseate
spoonbills in the world I'm just saying
do we all really need more of this
any kids come see the dirty pink
dinosaur is noisily devouring its young
and look there is a good argument to
make that helping people stay in their
homes after a disaster is what
government is for but remember a big
chunk of that money is just going to the
insurance companies and another
shockingly big chunk of that money goes
to very few homes for instance along the
Gulf Coast in Florida just 1% of
properties covered by the NFIP have
accounted for a quarter of flood claims
these are called the so called
repetitive loss properties now they are
homes that can flood over and over and
over again getting payments each and
every time and and some of them are
costing us a fortune just recently an
article in The Washington Post
highlighted a home in Pointe Coupee
Parish that has flooded 40 times while
the house is valued at just 56 thousand
dollars the NFIP is doled out nearly
four hundred thirty thousand dollars to
cover flood claims so that is just
stupid because if nothing else if your
house floods 40 times
mother nature is sending you a pretty
clear message and that message is hey
would you mind leaving some weird fish
would like to in here now and some
parts of the country have particularly
extreme examples of this now you
remember Mitch and Daniel the pastel
death trap that they were looking at is
on a place called dolphin Island where
over the past two decades
homeowners are paid just nine point
three million dollars in premiums into
the NFIP but they've received seventy
two point two million dollars in
payments for their damaged homes it is
so bad that the island got written up by
Bloomberg under the headline law of
coastal living is draining us disaster
funds and at first glance we thought
hold on isn't that the exact same
eyesore on stilts that Mitch and Daniel
almost bought well the good news is it's
actually not the bad news is it's
literally the house next door and it was
also featured on a different episode of
buying the beach
right in the water it wasn't close to
the beach it was in the ocean the waves
are just right here it's literally in
the ocean
this is in
yeah it is insane but what's even crazy
is at the end of the episode they
decided to buy the house but even if you
were able to overlook the repetitive
loss properties which you shouldn't
there is another issue and that is that
nearly one out of every five homes
covered under the NFIP is a second home
and because the program isn't
means-tested the benefits frequently go
to some wealthy individuals vacation
homes one such property belonged to John
Stossel a Fox News personality and
partially hydrogenated Tom Selleck and
I'll let Stossel who really answers the
question what a Freddie Mercury quit
scene to become an assistant floor
manager at Men's Wearhouse I'll let him
tell you all about it because even he
knew it was ridiculous years ago I built
this beach house that's younger me there
the house was on the edge of the
Atlantic Ocean a risky place to build
but I built anyway cuz a federal program
guaranteed my investment eventually a
storm swept away my first floor but I
didn't lose a penny thanks I never
invited you there but you paid for my
new first floor okay so now Stossel is
clearly just baiting people because
under no circumstances does anyone want
to be funding the reconstruction of the
world's smuggest man's rickety sea
prison and there is lots to be confused
about they're not not least of which
that photo of stossel posing shirtless
in skin tight white swim trunks from
hundreds of feet away who took that
photo
it can't be another human who wanted it
so here's my guess I think that he put a
camera on a long delay timer then
sprinted for a full 45 seconds back to
the deck of his house whispering hurry
hurry hurry to himself the entire time
and gone in position just in time for
that photo to happen that is the only
scientifically possible explanation we
debated this the entire week and
it's the only scenario that we can all
agree on
look if you choose to build something in
a risky place like John Stossel salt
battered bottoms only beach mistake you
should absolutely be allowed to do that
but you shouldn't expect the government
to repeatedly help you rebuild when
things inevitably go wrong however the
vast majority the vast majority here of
NFIP beneficiaries are not wealthy or
second home owners they often really
need this program and cannot afford for
it to go under and for those stuck in
repetitive loss properties it is easy
for anyone to just say they should move
they should just move but it's much more
difficult than that as this Kentucky
woman whose home has flooded repeatedly
will tell you we couldn't sell her house
who would want to buy a house with us
had this me repetitive floods and it who
would want to back us we have neighbors
that have had their houses up for sale
for two or three years and haven't even
had anyone come and view the house we
need a bath from from FEMA or from
whoever it is that is responsible for
this right and her decision to try and
leave that home could not have been easy
because you don't want to throw out the
baby with the flood water but at a
certain point the responsible thing to
do is to get a better more
water-resistant baby which is
incidentally also the title of Britain's
best-selling book on teaching children
to swim now unfortunately our by our
programs are hugely underfunded and
prohibitively slow it can take years for
buyouts to get approved by which point
homeowners have probably had to rebuild
their house at the government's expense
and it may have already flooded again so
essentially a government program that
was supposed to help people in flooded
homes is sometimes trapping them inside
them indefinitely and trapping people in
structurally unsound homes isn't what
the government is for it's what buying
the beach is for
there just has to be a better way here
and there are some key things that we
can do to improve this program we can do
things like means-tested and eventually
get rid of discounts for second hunks
and gradually increase the insurance
rates on some properties so that they
reflect actual risk unfortunately the
last time the Congress tried a major
reform of the NFIP with the
biggert-waters Act of 2012 the result
was that many people's rates skyrocketed
overnight and politicians were so
spooked by angry constituents they
significantly scaled back many of the
reforms and I'm not saying that this
will ever be politically easy because
even if you do properly fund and
streamline a buyout scheme there are
still going to be cases where people
just want to stay put right here in New
York there is a low line community
called Broad Channel where the streets
can flood twice a month its residents
fought against those rate increases a
few years ago and many of them have no
interest in leaving the neighborhoods to
great then this of my whole house got
destroyed by Sandy and ivory you know I
redid my whole house I do know people
like you're crazy you should move but
you're standing in water right now maybe
the people telling you to move we're
saying at the very least can you move up
five inches to dry land but the hard
truth here is even expensive
interventions are likely to only by that
community a little more time and people
in Broad Channel will eventually be
leaving whether it's by moving truck or
by boat because environmental conditions
are going to get worse heavy downpours
have increased in the last 50 years and
sea levels have been climbing steadily
and I'm not saying that that is because
of climate change
even though
just this precisely the NFIP is actually
two for reauthorization this December
and I would argue that it's time to take
another shot at serious thoughtful
reform because we're doubt it we have an
unstable unsustainable program that is
indirectly harming some of the people
that it was designed to help and I don't
have any type of joke relax I'm not here
for Tostitos really yeah hold on you can
talk of course CEOs can talk we just
choose to listen most of the time all
right
that's actually very nice and every word
you would say about flooding and you are
right I'm seated I'm a seagull yeah some
people in high-risk areas will need to
move and we should give them the help
that they can do that with right because
well leaving your home is hard being
forced out when it's uninhabitable is 10
times harder right and after all your
home isn't just walls and a roof it's
where the people you love uh-oh
see I'll call it that was absolutely
beautiful
yeah not bad for a flying beach rat oh
no no no no don't don't talk like that
about yourself no don't
it's okay I know it's true you know it's
true everybody watching knows it's true
Hey I eat french fries out of the
garbage yeah you're right you make a
good point you're absolutely disgusting
but but you know what I am truly sorry
for misjudging your motives in coming
here that's okay Johnny just one worth a
chore anything Jenny just Eidos you
have any Tostitos get all your get the
out of here
[Applause]